that's anti you know intellectualism
well that is what's taken over the party
the sort of anti it's almost as you know
there's almost a disdain with some
summoned Trump world they're like yeah
okay so the college-educated
crowd isn't forth this doesn't look like
an attempt to serve citizens
well looks like an attempt to only serve
the lead propagandist what feels like
we've reached a level of crazy in this
White House and it's difficult to take
take it anymore
every one of my colleagues on this
network grounds their arguments of fact
I've no doubt they have a point of view
but they grounded in facts
well that was NBC's so-called neutral
objective always objective anchor Chuck
Todd taking shots at Trump over what his
supporters also over the past couple of
years and in a new piece in the Atlantic
know he gets around mr. Todd advocates
for journalists to fight back against
conservative claims of bias bring it on
Chuck let me get this straight
while NBC is embroiled in multiple
scandals including completely blowing it
on the Weinstein sexual-assault story
Chuck Todd is telling Fox and others how
to handle its business nice try
joining me now with reaction
conservative radio talk show host Fox
News contributor Tammy Bruce and Chris
Han a liberal radio talk-show host and
former aide to Senator Chuck Schumer all
right Tammy take it away I find this to
be rich I mean it's nice to have a
byline in the Atlantic I get that and
taking shots at Fox is something of a
cottage industry out there but how much
credibility right at this moment does
NBC have well not much at all and I
think this is their breaking point but
it's also not an accident that this is
also just before the midterms of course
but let's look at Chuck Todd in the
Podesta emails that were leaked by
WikiLeaks we found that he hadn't been
inviting people to a party and that
Chuck Todd was having at his home for
Jennifer Palmieri a major aide for
Hillary Clinton and this is where but
you know in their private lives how they
all network together but there he's
arguing now that going 24seven against
the president United States is not
enough they now want to go
for seven against Fox News that's what
he's advocating for in the midst of
wondering why no one trusts the legacy
media and it's because they're
untrustworthy the American you can
actually see a Gallup poll tracks the
trustworthiness that that media enjoys
and when Fox News began in 1996 the
trustworthy index went up it went up for
a number of years and what you can see
when major events have occurred that
when the American trust mechanism the
the quotient for the media starts to go
down on major events like after
September 11th and and other dynamics so
you can just see you know they can fight
back Chuck Todd says in this piece he
wants to fight back he can fight back by
actually doing his job do report him
instead of creating you know it these
campaigns against people and blaming
everyone other than himself
yeah it's classic blame shifting and we
all know it's kind of easy to blame
other people and you've made mistakes
and we all do it but this is now at the
point where Kris Hana I think they see
that Fox most nights most of the time is
blowing the other networks out in the
ratings not always but we do pretty well
instead of having an actual debate on
the issues its Trump's bad Fox is bad
facts up Fox hosts are bad meanwhile
Ronan Farrow releases a statement last
night about what NBC had claimed Kris
about this Weinstein coverage saying
well we didn't was an adequately source
that's why we didn't go with Ronan's
reporting he says this last night
executives there have now produced a
memo that contains numerous false and
misleading statements or misleading
statements so I'll say briefly their
list of sources is incomplete omits
women who were either identified in the
NBC story or offered to be the
suggestion to take the story to another
outlet was first raised by NBC not me
and I took them up on it after it became
clear that I was being blocked from
further reporting the story was twice
cleared and deemed reportable by legal
and standards only to be blocked by
executives who refused to allow us to
seek comment from Harvey Weinstein so
covering up it looks like for a pal of
the network
pal of the executives and now lecturing
Fox get out of town Yuri ACK Wow look
look I mean I think anyone who helps and
assists somebody cover up the kind of
behavior that Harvey Weinstein
participated in you know needs to be
dealt with I don't know that that
extends to Chuck Todd he's allowed to
have an opinion on other things that is
separate from what the executive brass
may have done to cover up some bad
behavior
it happens all over the place it happens
there and I will say this though about
his article I read it I read every word
of it there are some things in an ayah
grew it there's some things I disagree
with it
one thing is that there are rebuttals on
Fox IRA but at least three times a week
on this network and I think I do a
pretty good job of it and but you know
there are kernels of truth in it
especially where he says conservatives
want to steer away from issues and go
towards wedge issues and symbolic issues
and it really did start a long time ago
long before Fox existed I think that the
conservatives moving in this country was
very small I think it's grown because
it's been able to exploit those wedge
issues much better than Democrats have
been at responding to those wedge issues
and moving the public towards issues
that matter when you say when you say
wedge issues they're issues that people
care about it's not a wedge and listen
about the issues whether the left did it
today at Kavanagh it was all about
abortion abortion abortion you're gonna
take away our guns you're gonna take
away our abortions so whose wedge issues
are we talking about here I mean the
left start of this was talking about
what I want to point out the part in the
article we talked about the Willie
Horton ad in 1988 I mean that's really a
fine example of taking something that is
a campaign that was a campaign my memory
serves me look I mean that's also
presidential campaign that's not the
media Chuck Todd's point was it was a
call for other media to attack this
network and Prateek individuals like
yourself sean hannity and tucker carlson
when in fact i mean look you've wedge
issues for them are issues that we all
care about that liberal
don't want to have be talked about like
immigration issues like like the
direction of health care like I mean
there's there's there's financial issues
the economy those kinds of things are
wedge issues they're all issues man all
about you know you guys guys hold on
there was another part we don't have the
full screen but I'm just gonna summarize
it there was a paragraph in the article
cuz someone sent it to me in circled the
part where I was meant to because I
didn't read the whole thing but I read
most of it it works as well and these
these primetime hosts are among the
conservative people who make a really
good living or something like that
selling their stuff we're opinion hosts
I don't pretend to be I'm not a network
anchor and object I'm gonna pin you
knows I've been doing this for 20 plus
years
okay since 1996 I was on MSNBC for the
first 15 minutes of the network okay so
I this this idea that people just popped
up there's one network out there like
Fox and in all of cable television and
it tends to beat the others and I love
having people who disagree on
I love having Chris on we love having
all of our guests on the left on or
Democrats because they offer a different
perspective and with that I'll let Chris
sum up look I love giving a different
perspective here and I think it's very
important to have both sides represented
I also think it's important for people
to get their media their news from a lot
of different places with a lot of
different opinions I've always watched
Fox I'm oh yeah I've always been
progressive but I've always watched Fox
a portion of my media diet so as I think
it's important for me to understand how
the other side of the aisle thinks and I
think everyone should look at both sides
of the aisle
fair point Tammy Chris thanks so much